[Musique]
il était une fois
des soeurs de titi titi il a dix ans
il est devant la télé un soir d'été en
1999 est tout près la télé parce qu'il
est mal voyants il est ma voix est là
bien vécu déjà à titiller à 10 ans parce
qu'il est né avec un club comme
congénitale son iris son cristallin fin
c'était déjà un petit peu le bordel de
la naissance à 3 ans il est vieux avant
l'âge légal il se fait opérer la
cataracte des deux veut c'est un truc
anormalement
cgg devait avoir un destin un petit peu
déjà écrit j'ai jours plus tard il
s'amuse à un cavalier dans une cage
d'escalier courez courez courez courez
en bail à une porte vitrée et splash
un premier ko
parce qu'ils voyaient fondre les gauches
relativement bien de les droits sauf
cuba le choc fait que des commandes
reaching de l'oeil droit il perd déjà la
vue de l'oeil droit
il est un peu casse cou et trois ans
plus tard
il prend un coup de pied dans les
gauches
ulcères de la cornée
et donc bâti ce sera là il est tout
proche de la télé devant une course de
démonstration
des preuves paralympiques 1 200 m de non
voyants qui sont guidés pendant les
championnats du monde 2 cv
je suis très loin d'impressionner ouais
c'est trop facile moi si un jour ce sera
champion du moule gérer un jeu
vous mes parents et comme
tous ceux qui étaient dans la pièce ce
jour là ont bien rigolé
bon il était quand même bienveillant et
ils ont tous dit ati tibet
c'est tout ce qu'on lui souhaite
ce que titine un petit peu des terres et
quelques semaines plus tard il a bien
l'intention de tenir parole donc s'ils
s'adressent au club de sa ville à
guyancourt dans les yvelines
et il arrive pour demander il n'est pas
très confiant parce qu'un entreprises
les clubs sportifs lors on lui ont fermé
ses portes que ce soit pour le basket le
judo
or la natation lui avaient dit oui mais
ce n'est pas maltraité lui envoyer des
planchers à la gueule ou des ceintures
autant dire qu'il avait pas trop kiffé
sauf que pour une fois la porte s ouvre
on lui fait une réponse on connaît ni le
handicap nil handisport mais viens viens
on va essayer de faire en sorte que tu
pratiques comme les autres
et c'est ce qu'ils vont pendant trois
ans tu vois pas liés pas de souci on va
mettre une lazio récente devant vu que
tu es mal ranch avec
la couleur tu vas réussir à le voir la
hauteur tu vois pas là bas c'est pas un
souci je vais la toucher avant de
prendre son élan et puis comme ça tu vas
visualiser un petit peu la longueur tu
vois pas la planche parce qu'avec la
vitesse n'arrive pas à le voir on va
mettre une écharpe de sauvetage orange
fluo et ainsi de suite j'ai la chance
et tu tiens la chance de de tomber sur
des gens qui veulent se creuser la tête
trouver des solutions tout simple parce
qu'il n'est pas question que le titille
concours en handisport il est très bien
avec les valides à ce moment là sauf
quand titi quelques semaines plus tard
et déménager
il retrouve pas structures qu'on lui dit
non ça ne nous intéresse pas on n'est
pas formé et quelques temps plus tard il
poursuit ses études
et la terry arrangés pour passer son bac
mais en début de lycée en seconde et
discute avec un éducateur
on lui apprend que est un club
d'athlétisme avec une section handisport
alors là je pars tout on y va on y va on
y va
et ils y arrivent confiants
vis ou l entraîneur il est pas bonjour
je voudrais faire du sprint du 100 et du
200 m mais je suis en train de perdre la
vue du coup j'ai besoin d'un guide
j'ai pas de temps à perdre avec un
aveugle à
une phrase quelques mois dévastateur
certains effectivement base aurait pu
abandonner
vu que j'étais petit je vous ai dit il
un petit peu têtu et un petit peu des
terres
alors il à faire volte-face s'il est
rentrés tête basse il a pleuré un bon
coup
puis en fait cette phrase ça a été
la sauce pour lui de d'une rage immense
et il a voulu faire taire sa terre tout
ce qui pouvait lui dire qu'il n'était
pas capable
surtout à un âge où effectivement il
était en train de perdre la vue 15 ans
veut se prouver des choses à soi même à
prouver ou jeu des choses aux autres on
veut plaire on veut s'accomplir voeckler
finit aussi
bref
j'attends de voir s'épanouir pendant
quelques temps dans d'autres activités
la musique de sport si possible il va
devoir redéfinir son projet
professionnel
à la base il voulait être ingénieur du
son on se dit chouette pour un aveugle
et va utiliser ce serait parce que moins
de 20% des études sont accessibles donc
là de la dure redéfinir
et puis 5e à 21 ans quand il est de
retour sur paris au détour d'une
conversation avec un ami
voilà la clé ça me manque trop
j'aimerais trop reprendre j'aimais 20 à
charléty dans le xiiie
il ya une section handisport ya plein de
mal voyants et déficients visuels qui
s'y entraîner en plus y en a qui sont à
niveau
non il va un petit peu occupé les mains
et poche
avec deux potes à lui puis demande à
parler à
responsable de la section athlétisme
et dit
bonjour j'ai perdu la vue il ya deux ans
avec un énième choc
à l'ailé gauche
je voudrais faire du sprint du 100 et du
200 m mais du coup j'ai besoin d'un
guide
et là il ya une voie avec un petit
accent burundais qui répond y'a pas de
soucis mais pourtant ça sera du casse en
agissant
combattu m'en veux pas
c'est pas de la moquerie
alors il a pas dit non mais ouais à 400
800 selon moi je veux faire du sein du
dos avec
bon j'étais galbées je voudrais m 84 60
kg aujourd'hui je peux rien n'est fait
mais j'ai pris parce qu'il a entre temps
et c'est gagné aussi que l' aventure
commence ils me demandent de revenir à
un mois plus tard le temps qui me trouve
un guide
il tient parole
entre moins d'entraînements bat le
record de france du 800 m et il continue
à monter les échelons ainsi de suite
les sélectionnés pour
présélectionner pardon pour les jeux de
londres
ce sera un échec pas si longtemps qu'il
a repris
et quand toute l'équipe de france est
elle à londres lui reprend sa
préparation pour les championnats du
monde de l'année suivante 2013 en se
promettant de ne plus jamais connaître
ce sentiment
d'avoir échoué
il va s'entraîner comme un dingue
pendant un an encore et encore pourtant
à trois mois des championnats du monde
il se blesse
me lâche pas la faire
il arrive à se qualifier
sur la ligne de part il fait bien
gringalet tombe sans demande un petit
peu ce qu'il fout là pour le coup et à
la surprise générale il se qualifier en
finale des championnats du monde sur 400
m
la veille de cette finale
arte mon
qui je n'ai pas dit tout à l'heure c'est
l'art témoin toungui mana du champion du
monde du 800 m sur 1900 en 1995 vers une
légende kelly slater j'ai passé sa part
à certains d'entre vous il lui dire
écoute tu n'es pas assez costaud demain
tu seras pas le lion du sahara les
guépards blanc
alors le lendemain sur cette ligne de
départ il est bien décidé à donner
raison à son entraîneur même si personne
n'y croit
mais même si je sais pas vraiment s'il y
croire son entraîneur lui répète qu' il
sera sur le podium mais bon ça semble
pas l'être de l'avis de tous
il ya un peu têtu et puis il un peu de
challenger aussi alors il donne tout ce
qu'il a et il va obtenir sa première
médaille internationale sur un cas
science cassant la gueule sur l'année si
je tombais pas en fait il aurait pas eu
sa médaille
quel que part blanc commence son
histoire l'année suivante il est double
champion d'europe 200/400 m il aurait pu
faire le triplé mais son guide il a fait
faux départ sur le 100 m et qu'on lui
aussi
symétrie sens mais si ce n'était pas
juste expliqué calmement
en train parce qu'on aurait pu sans
bruit dans ces cas là vous imaginez vous
êtes favoris du 100 m d'un 100 mètres et
votre partenaire il fait il fait faux
départ aux est éliminé
ben non c'est juste parler
et le lendemain ils ont été champions
d'europe pour un centième
juste parce que ils ont su rebondir
ensemble
en 2015
de bronze aux championnats du monde à
nouveau sur 400 m l'ami 16 champion
d'europe sur 100 m 200 sauf que le
guépard blanc ben c'est comme les
pokémon ça évolue
et devient chat noir
disqualifié en finale des championnats
d'europe sur 400 mètres alors qu'il a
été médaille d'argent pour une poussette
dans le dos de la part de son guide
où je vis est présente en étant un grand
favori
en tout cas un des grands prétendants au
podium sur 100 et sur 400 histoire de
pas faire comme les autres parce que
d'habitude un athlète eut fait 60 cents
soit 2 cents 400 milles avait essayé de
faire 100 400 il est pas son nom il faut
grand écart quand même
j'espère qu'ils ont sortis de cet art en
demi finales du 100 m qui devait être
une formalité
fracture de la glène arrachement des
ligaments décollement de la capsule d
insertion complète eu pour les non il
n'était pas groen pour laisser un muscle
il évalue sa course malgré ton sauf
qu'il manque un millième un millième
pour qu'ils rentrent en finale
le staff médical lui dire écoute vuleta
ton épaule la titille c'est fini le jeu
alors donnons
gracieux 400 cm aspect vous avez cinq
jours vous débrouiller mais dans cinq
jours sera sur la piste vous strappé
vous on va tous mobilisés laisse nous
tranquille s'il te plaît
au niveau on prépare ce 400 ha tu es
sérieux
fait il bon le strapper vont tester à
l'entraînement sur une seule course sur
1 300 qu'on a eu à la loupe dans 400 se
plaît en fait baptiste il est sur les
bases du record du monde
même avec une épaule péter nous conduit
du bas tu vas courir
et même avec ça ils se retrouvent en
demi-finale
contre le voc en main du monde champion
du monde en titre qu'elle brésilien je
le rappelle on herriot
et thibault il très stressée mais il
gagne la course
même dans ses rêves les plus fous il
pensait pas gagner comme ça sauf qu'une
minute après l'arrivée on le disqualifie
pour avoir mis un pied sur la ligne
sofia aucune image de ce pied sur la
ligne il ya trois demi finales deux
demi-finales où il ya des brésiliens et
c'est bizarre dans cette demi-finale ya
des disqualifications
c'est vrai qu'on les brésiliens jeu
précis c'est juste des raisons
géopolitiques
contre laquelle non en tant que sportif
on peut rien faire en 2017 il
la tête ce soir de la finale des
championnats du monde à londres du 400 m
sauf qu il est tellement lactique à deux
mètres de la ligne s'écroule son qu'il
passe la ligne avant lui il est
disqualifié
en finale du 200 m qui gagnent il est
champion olympique en 45 minutes c'est
le temps de pleurer dans les pâles dans
les bras de ses parents
il fait les interviews pour l'intérieure
américaine ben bernanke avant nous
annonce en fait qu'il est disqualifié
parce que bien peu ont régalé comme je
dédie l'épaule de son guide un petit peu
plus costaud il est passé devant lui
pour trois millièmes donc il perd son
titre de champion du monde
en 2018 il fut champion d'europe du 100
m mais il croit que ça y est le guépard
blond est de retour mais non surtaxé
match et gagnent avec 25 mètres balance
quasiment deux mois
mais ont disqualifié juste ma mère
avant de monter sur le podium parce
qu'en fait
ils avaient oublié lui met son dossard
avant mais cette fois capable un peu
frustré il se fait chier depuis des
années parce que bon ça fait trois ans
quand même chez les plus opérationnels
en 2009 il va rougir de nouveaux effets
champion du monde du 400 m haies du
champion du monde du 100 m
et là il est prêt à affronter les jeux
de tokyo enfin la revanche sociale un
coin qui s'appelle covit qui vient
[ __ ] la merde un peu dans ses plans
qui a foutu amène un peu de magie tout
le monde je passe ce qu ils étaient en
stage à la réunion fait trois jours
qu'il est arrivé il a payé pour 36 guide
un entraîneur qui n'est besoin de dieu
mon gars fort intérêt parce que
elle convie tous les stades sont fermés
ben on va faire un trou dans le grillage
et puis on va aller s'entraîner pendant
quinze jours en 16e et 15 mille ballons
les jettent pas comme ça
on était dans les bras
sauf que deux semaines après deux
semaines d'entraînement intensif de
semaine où tu vois la forme qui monte on
était prêts les prêts à aller chercher
la qualif
est serré prochaine c'est pas de cap moi
c'est dans 16 pays bas en fait on va
mettre 1 confirmant donc appelé à
contrer avec tanguy d'un manga tu vas
rester chez toi donc là faut trouver une
solution pour rester en vie alors dit il
achète un vélo et il va pédaler pédaler
pendant un bon mois et demi
bon c'est parfois risquée même s'il a
dormi entre temps m et puis père prend
le chemin de l'entraînement il fait une
bonne préparation
il devient champion d'europe et champion
de champion d'europe du 400 vice
champion d'europe du 100 m en étant le
quatrième aveugle à passer sous la barre
des 11 secondes le premier européen
et donc ils abordent les jeux avec une
cible dans le dos clermont champion du
monde en titre du 400 m championne
d'europe et se lancent sur ce tour de
piste
égale sa demi finale en étant couloir un
couloir le plus pourri campus 1 de
donner un athlète
sauf que
ben c'est pendant un chat noir est bien
est là et on le disqualifie d'un nouveau
son lien a été lâché par le guide à 45
centimètres de la ligne d'arrivée
petit il est bien déterminé à
pas rentré du japon sans rien il va tout
donner sur
sur le 100 m
ce qu'il ya un regret qu'il est un peu
relou
et on sait que il va avoir une bataille
au sommet de fait 10 98 aux europe nous
10 99
explication de texte en finale
prévus et programmés mais voilà bien
lieu
le grec fait 10 81 2 encore dû monter un
temps de 10 92 ont fait 10 90 aussi vous
l'avez compris titi c'est moi j'ai plus
court sur ces dix années parce que j'ai
rencontrés ainsi une multitude de guide
aujourd'hui je suis le plus gros
consommateur de guide je m'explique tous
les adversaires ils ont un ou deux
guides hockey de compétition en guise
d'entraînement on guide par distance non
avec arte monde a voulu avant la même
troupe préparation canal kate honda
olympique de haut niveau et du coup ça
nécessite que le groupe s'entraîne de
son côté donc je peux pas faire 25
heures d'entraînement avec moi à 25
heures d'entraînement pour lui c'est pas
trouvent aussi
leur mais ce ne serait pas très d'accord
c'est 50 heures d'entraînement par
semaine ça fait beaucoup de massage à
faire
il faut un peu
bref
ben tiens il a aussi un truc c'est qu'il
voit rien mais il voit loin ils ont bien
élargir les horizons il faut aussi de la
musique
vont transmettre des messages
futur stand up pour casser tous ses
codes et ses idées reçues qu'on a sur le
handicap et puis pouvoir essayer de
rendre la pareille parce qu'on n'a plus
donné dans sa vie l'a décidé
puisqu'il a mis un peu joueur donc
la première entreprise qui va concevoir
et distribuer des jeux mobiles grand
public accessible à tous types de
handicaps parce que on parle
d'accessibilité aujourd'hui mais la
culture moderne et le jeu vidéo il en a
rien à [ __ ] très clairement donc
c'était une question d'innover
et donc pour conclure
je dirai juste que si vous avez un petit
itier qui résonne un peu avoue
son petit voix vous allez juste avant le
choc à un truc ne rêve pas tu allumes
éviter rêve merci
[Musique]